Espera que se pronuncie las próximas
horas agentes que están en la calle de
esta policía de carretera federal dicen
que Cuanto más tiempo callado más pueden
aumentar esos actos de insubordinación y
que en la primera vez que un presidente
no se pronuncia después de tanto tiempo
no tiene precedente primero por sonar es
el primer presidente que no consigue la
reelección y segundo es el presidente
que no reconoce su derrota y no felicita
a su rival Esto no se había visto nunca
de nuevo en los bastidores se piensa que
bolsonaro esté esperando para ver si la
protesta de Los camioneros se extiende a
la población pero parece que está
aislado